and we are here with
buzzfeed to rank all of our songs which
if this song is our actual favorite
so all of our songs are gonna be spread
out in a bracket and with each pairing
we'll have to decide
which song we like more yeah let's get
it
versus nobody like you first of all i
want to say that we
love all of our songs yeah three two
one i like you because our first
song yeah that's right and many people
lots of our fans really liked this song
so i think it's
a great song i see versus sorry not
sorry oh
this is tough three two one stop
[Applause]
is really great song yeah but we prefer
sorry not sorry more
yeah i love my party in serena
oh yeah show them
the best
she has attractive voice yeah yeah
that's true
versus one what it oh three
two one not shy
they're both good but not shy yeah it's
summer
and wild wild west
three two one is hard
i really like it's somewhere by but
it's one of my favorites yeah from this
album so yeah it's really hard
if i have to have a pool party i would
put on its own
yeah yeah pool party and matches kidding
me
and the 24 hours okay three
two one twenty four hours anything
for 24 hours they're kind of different
24 hours really different like base and
like the what
what
some of my favorite songs i don't wanna
dance
of course this is also a good song too
three two one in the morning
yeah it's upcoming our title song yep
everyone stay tuned all right
is also a good song very energetic and
itchy style the vibe is cheerleading
yeah
so i love that five so i choose
don't give a what i think you think it's
really good songs yeah
this song is more addictive and more
exciting and more high team yeah
more like true like session and thinking
would be a more
kind of like trendy yeah then louder
versus
shoes
new type of song that we never tried
very new
yeah and ryrics and sound is
very addictive
right now
because our favorite song is one of them
when did we get this teamwork it's weird
okay next up is id and cherry
it's very hard totally different style
and they're both good and i know that
our members like them both yeah
it's cherry terry
[Applause]
but i really like ideas
i like cherry but um more i think
it's more it's true it's cheerful and
high style tell me i think
so our pick is cherry cherry oh my god
next
video
both of us really are really really
favorite
[Music]
is
really my style that's no no
and tennis three two
one
yeah i love the vibe of the sun yeah and
i like that that
i like that's a no-no too but my
favorite is tennis
[Applause]
[Music]
time to move on to sorry not sorry okay
not shy versus
wow oh both of them sounds like
like western yeah
yeah yeah three two one
but the only reason i think yeah uh i
picked why why west and probably lots of
us is because
we listened to so many so many yeah
so we're kind of like more into our new
songs recently
that could be 24 hours and
in the morning three
two
yeah as i said it's our newest recent
song
yeah and also it's our title song so
it's like the most confident song that
we have right now
so yeah and then our new challenge new
challenge hip-hop
vibe song and so excited
okay next up is ting ting ting and shoot
use the ting ting ting i'm
[Music]
one two three
be in love versus that's a no-no oh
weak at like sash songs like being looks
kind of like a sad song
too sorry nasa rivers this is
wild wild west oh it's the wild wild
west
so i picked the story now sorry how
about you too
[Music]
arches
[Music]
our pick is in the morning
and shoot oh this is easy three two two
one in the morning
wanna be versus be in love one two
three now guys
we have to decide wild wild west versus
in
the morning three two one in the morning
yeah in the morning
bye bye bye this is finer in the morning
versus canopy three two
one our
pick is in the morning
yay because for me i like wannabe but i
prefer being like more than wanna be but
i would prefer in the morning more than
be in love so that would stay in there
yeah yeah i think i have to cheer in the
morning
because she's our baby thank you
birthdays
and be sure to check out our in the
morning bye thank you
[Music]
you